a la traen de afuera la violencia lata
al gobierno con su médico se queja
carolina soto líder de la etnia indígena
mapuche sobre la decisión del gobierno
de regresar al ejército a las regiones
de araucanía y bío bío una opinión que
comparten la mayoría de los mapuches del
sur del país el conflicto en esta zona
viene de largo los mapuches consideran
que esa tierra les pertenece por
derechos ancestrales de mapuche de la
tierra el mapuche vive de la tierra es
el sustento del mapuche la tierra a mí
no me interesan los palos de la floresta
a mí me interesa la tierra porque yo en
la tierra voy a comer
voy a vivir voy a criar y van a crecer
mi hijo libre y es que el estado tiene
una vieja deuda con la etnia a la que no
ha reconocido como pueblo hasta el
momento algo que la constituyente
pretende cambiar al definir a chile como
un estado plurinacional si finalmente
sale adelante la reforma a la carta
magna del país al respecto el presidente
gabriel boric había apostado por el
diálogo con los mapuches pero el giro en
su política al rey a las tropas ha
decepcionado a muchos el gobierno del
presidente boris gobierna con la misma
ley y k gobernado todo y mientras eso no
cambie yo yo veo que va a ser difícil la
forma de que cambien en la zona la vida
no transcurre con normalidad los
enfrentamientos y atentados son
habituales de hecho el argumento del
envío de tropas se reforzó tras la
muerte de un hombre de 66 años en la
localidad de lumaco una situación que
los expertos sostienen no se solucionará
sin diálogo entre las dos partes